Thank you.
So I. I was thinking, earlier.
Like, what idiot scheduled
this talk at this time?
And, like.
Because immediately
afterwards, I
have to go and introduce
Joe for the keynote.
And of course, the idiot was me.
So today I want
to give you a bit
of a first look at this new
OOP system for R called R7.
And obviously like
I'm giving this talk,
but I didn't do all
the work for this talk.
This is a joint effort from
the R Consortium working group
on object oriented programming.
So I'll talk a little
bit about that later
because I think that's a really
important part of this project.
This is not just like
some idea that I've had,
it's a team effort from a number
of very important stakeholders
in the R community.
But to begin, I wanted to
kind of talk about like,
why do we need OOP?
And I want to do that by talking
about this bizarro function.
And the goal of this bizarro
function is to take an R object
and turn it upside down somehow.
So for example, if we've
got a numeric vector,
maybe we'll flip the sign.
Or if we've got a logical
vector, maybe I'll turn
true to falses and
falses to trues.
Or if I've got a
character vector,
I'll flip the letters in each
of the strings in that vector.
Or if I've got a factor,
I'll flip the levels.
And if there's anything
else, I'll just throw an error.
So what's wrong
with this function?
Well, there's nothing really
wrong with this function
because it's so simple.
Like you can already
see it on one slide.
But there are some problems with
this kind of general approach.
And the first one is like as
we handle more and more types
of data, this function is
going to get bigger and bigger
and bigger, and you're
going to have all
of that code in a single file.
And if you think about
functions in base R
that have to have
different behavior
for different types of things.
This is going to become
really problematic
and I think the
function in base R
that does the most different
things for the most different
types of objects is print.
And if you were to write print
with this kind of if-else style,
like this is what it
looks like just for the,
the types of objects in base R
that begin with a letter
A. Like that's already not
enough to fit on a
slide and I haven't even
included the implementations.
So you can imagine
as this gets, as you
deal with more and
more types of things,
it's getting bigger and
bigger and bigger.
And the other possibly
more important problem
is that there's
only one person who
can add new types of
behavior to that function,
that they can teach that function
to handle new types of object,
and that's the original author.
And again, you can
imagine for R core,
like if every time someone
added a new type of thing,
a new class, that some code in
R itself would have to change,
that's obviously going to
be a huge, huge hassle.
So that's really the inspiration
for OO programming in R.
But there are already two
types of OO systems in R.
So why do we have S4?
Well, how does R7 fit in?
Well, first of all, we
have S3 or mama bear.
Now S3 was it has its
name because it was the OOP
system developed for the third
version of the S programming
language.
It really is the
simplest OOP system
that could possibly work.
It works basically
mostly on conventions.
It doesn't have a lot of
structure and it works great,
but it's very, very simple.
And then a few years later, as
kind of a reaction to history,
along came Papa Bear, S4.
And S4 is very
strict, very rigorous.
It's a lot you get a
lot more guarantees,
but it's also a lot more
complicated and a lot more
work.
So S4, so-called because it was
designed for the fourth version
of the S programming language.
And so now we've been working
on this tool called R7,
where we want to be--
We want to try and
be like baby bear.
We want to be like just right.
We want to strike the right
balance between complexity
and power.
And we're calling it
R7 because it's
hopefully like 3 plus 4, like
the best parts of S3 and S4
and it's designed for
R, not for like backward
compatibility with S.
So what would it
look like if we were
going to implement this
bizarro function in R7?
Well, the first thing we have
to do is load the R7 package,
and this is kind of
probably temporary.
So currently R7 is just
a package on GitHub.
Hopefully in a few months
it'll become a package on CRAN,
but the long term goal is
to get it into R itself.
So this doesn't this is not
an additional dependency.
This is something
that's built into R.
But for now, we're going
to load that package.
And then we're going to
create a generic, and a generic
as a special type of function
whose behavior depends
on the type of one or
more other functions.
So here we're defining
a new generic.
And crazily enough, we're
going to use a function called
new generic to do
that, and we're
going to give that function
the name of the generic.
So bizaro.
And we're also going to store
that result in a variable
called bizarro, that is
going to be our generic.
So it's a little bit
unfortunate that we've got
to have this repetition here.
We're saying bizarro twice.
We considered a number of
ways to work around this
and decided that this was
the least worst solution
was this a little
bit of repetition.
There's one other
argument here, and that
is the name of the
argument that's
going to be used for dispatch.
Dispatch is the process of
finding the implementation,
given the type of the argument.
So this generic, like,
doesn't really do anything.
There's no code here, right?
There's no implementation.
But it kind of defines the
shape of what this function is
going to look like.
And if we want to add
implementation, what we
have to do is define methods.
So if we go back to that bizarro
function, look at that first
if block if is numeric x what
we're going to do now instead
of an if block is we're
going to define a method.
And we're going to define
that method with the method
function.
The first argument of the
method is the generic,
and the second
argument to the generic
is the type of object we want
to provide an implementation
or a method for.
And so here we're going
to use a built-in class.
This is something a numeric
vectors of something that come
built into R something
that R7
is going to provide for you.
And then we provide the
implementation, which
is exactly the same as before.
So the implementation
has not changed.
But the way we get to
that implementation,
instead of having a bunch
of if-else statements,
we're going to use this,
this method lookup.
And so if we work through
the other methods,
the logical exactly
the same thing.
Now instead of testing,
if it is dot  logical,
we say we're defining a method
for the bizarro generic
with logical class.
Same thing for
character and so on.
And once we've done
that, the generic
is going to work
exactly the same way
as our original function.
Nothing's going to differ there,
except that when we call it
with some type of object we
haven't provided a method for,
we're going to get a
slightly different error
message because we're
going to say the R7 R7
system is going to
say, well, I can't
find a method for an object
that's a function.
If we print that
generic, we can see
that this is an R7 generic
that has a bunch of methods.
And if you're paying
attention, you
might notice that there
are four methods there.
But I only just
defined three methods.
And that's because
the numeric class
is a little bit of a fiction.
In R there isn't really
such a thing as
a numeric vector.
A numeric vector is either
actually an integer vector
or a double vector.
And that's what you
can see in this class.
Now, you've probably
already you've
probably seen a similar
thing if you've ever
printed an S3
generic. But this is what
it S3 generic looks like.
So if you've ever been
hunting for the source
code for a function and you
see this weird use method
call, that tells you you're
dealing with an S3 generic.
And so one of the things we've
tried to do with R7
is to be a little
bit more helpful.
When you look at a generic,
it's going to tell you,
hey, this is a generic
and these are the methods
that I know about.
And those four methods there
which look like function calls,
those are actually
function calls.
And if you copy and paste
that code into your console,
you'll see the implementation
of each of those methods.
So there are two parts to
object oriented programming
systems in R. Generics-
generic functions which define
behavior, and classes, which
define data.
So I've shown you generics.
And now I want to show you
a little bit about what
classes in R7 look like.
So I'm going to
create a new class.
Surprise, surprise.
I'm going to use a function
called new class to do that.
I'm going to call
it a range class.
Again, I'm going to assign
the result of that function
to an object with the
same name as the class,
and that is going to produce
what we call the constructor
function.
This is both kind
of a definition
of the class and
the thing you're
going to use to create instances
or objects of that class.
This class has some properties.
So properties are the data
that an object possesses.
If you've used S3 before,
this is the same as attributes.
If you've used S4,
these are the same as slots.
So these are the, the, the data
that every object of this range
class is going to
possess, every one is going
to have a start property
and an end property
that are both numeric vectors.
So now that we've created that
object, that class object,
that class constructor, we
can create range objects
just by calling that function.
We can print it.
We get some information
about the data that's in it,
and we get this
hint that maybe we
can access the values
inside that object
with the at symbol.
So if you've ever
used S4 before,
that's the way you
extract data out
of objects in the S4 with
that and R7 takes that.
So you can get values,
you can set values.
But R7 has kind of got
some built in safety rails
so that if you try
and assign a character
vector to that x property that
we said had to be a numeric,
you're going to get an error.
But that doesn't protect you
against every possible error
or every possible way you
might create an invalid object.
Because you might
say, well, actually I
want to have a range object
where the start is always
less than the end, and there's
currently nothing stopping me
from creating invalid ranges
just by using a larger
start than an end.
You can resolve that
in R7 by providing
something called a validator.
A validator is just a
function that takes an object
and either says,
all as well, or it
returns a message telling you
what is wrong with that object.
And so once you
supply a validator,
then that is going to
ensure that every instance
of that object has to be valid.
It's very well,
it's still it's R,
it's still possible to
create an invalid object,
but you've got to jump
through some hoops to do that.
And this is a really valuable,
really valuable property
because this means that if you
have a range object, you know
that start is always
going to be less than end.
You know that these
conditions are true,
which is really useful.
Another really cool
thing you can do
is you can make properties
that aren't actually data
that are computed on demand.
They behave exactly as if there
was some data behind them.
But you can do
basically anything you
want inside these properties.
So these work a little like
active bindings if
you've used those before.
But this is a really important
aspect of R7,
which which I'll come back
to a little bit later.
So that that's kind of
R7 in a nutshell.
But how does it kind of compare
to S3 and S4?
Well, I think if we're going
to compare OO systems,
it's good to think about what's
the complexity, how hard it
is to use,
and what's the payoff.
And S3 has a very,
very low complexity.
It's very, very simple, and
the payoff is relatively low.
S4 the payoff is
much, much higher,
but the complexity is
also much, much higher.
And so our goal with R7 is
to create something that's
just a little bit more
complex than S3, but has
almost all of the features,
all of the payoff of S4.
Now, whenever I
hear about someone
trying to solve a problem with
there's two existing solutions
by creating a third
solution, I always
think of this XKCD comic.
And we really want to
avoid this with R7.
And we don't want to make
the whole problem more
complicated by now giving
people three possible choices
of object oriented programming
instead of the two that
are baked into base R.
Not to mention like the
five or six other packages
on CRAN that have other object
oriented programming systems.
So how are we going to do that?
Well, first of all,
this is a team effort.
The R Consortium working group
on object oriented programming,
it's the mouthful, includes
representatives from R Core,
from Bioconductor,
from our rOpenSci,,
from RStudio, the tidyverse,
and the general R community.
This is not an effort to
solve the problems of just
a small group of people,
but this is an effort
to solve the problems faced
by a large proportion of the R
community.
Next, we're trying
to take what we
believe to be the best
parts of S4 and keep them.
And that's like the formal
definition of classes.
So when you get an object of a
specific type, you know a bunch about it
right off the bat. That at
helper, which gives you
a useful error message if
you try to extract something
that does not exist.
R7 also provides multiple
dispatch when needed,
which is really important
for errors like for example,
arithmetic operations
where you need
to choose the implementation
based on the left hand
side and the right
hand side of addition.
And finally, we have
this validator function,
which allows us to apply
additional conditions to make
sure our objects are valid.
And we've tried to do that
while keeping R7 100%
backward compatible with S3.
So if you have an
existing S3 class,
you can convert it
to R7 in such a way
that everyone who
uses that object,
if it's an R7 object,
gets all of these new goodies
but no existing code breaks.
And one of the ways
we've done this
is a little weird in
terms of the spectrum
of object oriented programming
systems and other environments.
So one of the core
precepts of OO programming
is normally encapsulation.
And that means like
only the person
who writes a class can access
the data inside that class.
And this is, I think, a really
good idea in 99% of programming
languages. But it
doesn't really work in R
because the people who
use R are a data scientists,
and they want that
data inside that object
and they would do
whatever it takes
to get that object if they
want it to get that data,
if they want it.
So S4 tried to
kind of protect people
from this. Like you
never as a user,
you're not really supposed
to use the at symbol.
You're always supposed to
use some kind of accessor
function, but it just
didn't really work.
People want that data.
And so instead,
R7 is designed around
like, rather than trying to fight
this very natural tendency,
R7 accepts it while
giving you the ability
to change the
internals of your class
if you need to with
these dynamic properties.
So if you have
to, you can change
the internal
implementation, you can
deprecate fields, properties
inside your object
and still have existing
code work, which
is a really important property to
allow code to evolve over time.
And then finally, we've
tried to dig a pit of success
with thoughtful function names,
argument names, documentation
and errors.
So hopefully after you've
used it a little bit,
you can start to guess
what the code you need is,
and if that guess
is slightly wrong,
you will get useful
feedback that points you
in the right direction.
So really, really,
really appreciate it
if you would, try
out R7.
As I said, it's currently
a GitHub package
which you can install
pretty easily if you want.
We'd love to know not just
what doesn't work
or how it doesn't help
you solve your problems,
but we also want to know
what doesn't make sense.
What don't you understand?
Like, where are the problems
in the documentation,
where are the problems
in the error messages,
so that we can do
better and that we
can make R7 just right.
Thank you.